hey everyone this is ravi from simply
learn
welcome to this instagram marketing full
course video for 2021.
in this full course video we'll be
covering topics like the steps you need
to follow to create an instagram video
things you need to do to increase
followers the process of instagram
marketing and how instagram differs from
facebook
for this video we have our experts rob
and rahul
taking us through all the topics so
without further ado
let's start by talking about how to
create instagram videos
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit that bell
icon
to never miss an update from simply
learn
instagram how to section
instagram is one of the fastest growing
social media networks
its appealing format and functionality
have driven
people and businesses away from
traditional networks like facebook
video content is the most popular
content type on instagram
so it's obvious that we need to dedicate
one lesson to how to create
optimize and promote your video posts on
instagram
we will start this lesson with showing
you how to make great instagram videos
and talk about the different types of
videos for instagram
and we will then demo you how to use the
various video capturing and editing
tools
you will find in the instagram app we
will close this lesson with how
businesses can use instagram
and how you can make money with it
instagram has extensive features to
create and promote videos
particularly with the growing appetite
in using instagram stories
video is the most important content form
on instagram
it is important though to make sure that
before you start creating your video
you have a good idea of what you want to
achieve with it
is it to create awareness to generate
leads
or are you answering questions that
clients may have
utilize the video editing features that
instagram has or
use some external apps if you want to go
beyond
what instagram has to offer there are
enough tools for you to make your
instagram video
a visual feast as you can only create
that on instagram
shooting and editing a great video
video is now the most shared content
type on instagram
where in the early days instagram video
was only 15 seconds long
nowadays you can upload 60 second videos
and turn multiple videos from your
camera roll into one video clip
and today instagram has lots of
different options within the app to
create videos
and optimize them for the newsfeed or
for stories
recently instagram announced igtv
they're trying to take on youtube with a
dedicated video sharing app for vertical
and landscape videos
with a maximum length of 60 minutes for
verified accounts or accounts with a
large audience
however anyone using the app will be
able to upload
up to 10 minutes of content to the
platform all in all
instagram today is a fantastic network
for brands
to build brand awareness and to showcase
their products or services
to shoot great videos for instagram you
need to be aware
of a few things first of all you need to
shoot the video for instagram and
instagram has its own video formats
video for the news feed tend to be
square whereas video for the stories
must be vertical
the aspect ratio for vertical videos is
9 by 16
which gives you a perfect 90 degrees
flip for normal widescreen video
it's also better to use your phone's
native camera
this will give you better control over
exposure and focus
instagram will allow you to upload
multiple clips
and then edit them within the instagram
app
also think about short form versus long
form videos stories
are good for short clips whereas igtv
lends itself for longer videos short
videos are great for explaining things
that can be chopped up in steps like
recipes
or how-to videos long videos are good
for brand experiences
and interviews additionally it goes
without saying
you always need to think about what you
want to achieve with your video
what's your end goal do you want new
followers
do you want to get into engagement with
your followers
or do you want to drive traffic to your
website
all questions you need to think about
before you start shooting your video
video editing in external apps
once you have shot your video you can do
some basic editing
within the instagram app you can also
edit your video outside instagram
the best environment for editing your
video is on your desktop computer
apps like adobe premiere from microsoft
or imovie from apple
will give you an extensive range of
video and audio editing options
you can then save the edited file and
move it to your phone via google drive
for instance after which you can import
the video file
into instagram there are also many video
editing apps for your mobile
they won't give you as many features as
the desktop video editing
but they come a long way one of my
favorite apps is video show
what i like about video show is that it
has a wide range of templates you can
use
as a format for your edited video
it also comes with an extensive song and
music library
video categories so
what type of video would work best on
instagram
instagram lends itself for what we call
snackable videos
a snackable video is short compelling
and entertaining and they are designed
to drive the viewer to some sort of
action
like driving them to a landing page or
to a fill-in form
here are some examples of topics for
your next instagram video
it can feature your product features to
show your followers what products you
carry
and why those products are unique you
can show your product in action
this is great for breaking up the
monotony of staged product features
you can also give a sneak preview in
these type of videos
you announce news with a teaser which
gives your followers
a sneak peek of what is to come behind
the scene videos work very well on
instagram
they are great for building a more
personal relationship with your
audience think of office tours staff
introductions
a day in the life of tutorials
will show your fans how to use your
product
and finally video series
they are great for building a community
and for engaging with them
once your community has seen an episode
and they like it
they may want to come back for more
video types besides different topics for
your videos
you can also think about different
formats for your videos
looping videos can be created within the
instagram app
looping videos start automatically from
the beginning after the clip finishes
they can be very creative and work well
to showcase movable product features
stop-motion video is an animation that
is captured
one frame at a time with physical
objects that are moved between frames
when you play back the sequence of
images rapidly
it creates the illusion of movement both
ios and android have lots of apps to
create
stop-motion video in a time-lapse video
you capture lots of photos of a scene
over a period of time
these images are then put together to
create a seamless sped up video
time-lapse videos work very well to show
how something is built or made
and finally hyperlapse videos these are
videos that allow you to squeeze
several minutes of film into the one
minute maximum set by instagram
they are a bit like time lapse videos
but the camera is moving
these videos are great to show behind
the scene footage
how to use instagram video options
there are various ways that you can make
a video on instagram
so let me show you how to do that if you
go to the instagram app
it takes you to the news feed where you
can browse
to make a quick video you just click on
the plus button
and that takes you to this shot of my
phone for instance
you need to make sure you activate video
if you click on the button you can then
make your video
you click again to stop recording and
your video is ready
you can now play the video and if you
are happy with it you click
next and then you can add a filter if
you want to
i will come back to filters and editing
later
then you just click next write the
caption tag
people add a location and share it
your video is now posted on instagram
this is the simple way there's also a
more advanced way of making your video
so let me discard this video go back to
the news feed
we're now in the news feed the creative
way to create a video is
go to your instagram stories
to access your instagram stories you can
swipe to the right
or you can also click on the little
camera on the top left of your screen
that takes you to the same video screen
and now you see
that you have more options you can see
that here at the bottom
you can do live video you can do normal
video
you can select boomerang video you can
do super zoom
you can focus on your video rewind your
video and record hands-free
so let me explain these in a bit more
detail
for normal video you just click on the
video button
and then you can see that it's recording
and when you're ready with the recording
then you let go of the button and what
you see now
is that you have some extra options at
the top where you can add effects
stickers drawings or text
so this is the simple way of making a
video with added effects
you can also go for live video and this
is just like facebook live
when you click on go live then instagram
will announce it to your followers
and then you can start your live
broadcast when you're ready with your
live broadcast
instagram will ask you if you want to
post it on your stories
or in your news feed and then you're
done with your broadcast
a very creative way of making videos
is using boomerang boomerang was a
separate app
which became very popular it was then
acquired by instagram
a boomerang video is a video that
repeats itself
if i click on boomerang i'm going to get
the phone and i will turn it
then when you look at the video i
created you see how the video repeats
itself all the time
you can do a lot of creative things with
the boomerang effect
you can make people move back and
forwards you can make objects move up
and down
and then post them as short repeating
videos
you also see that you can change the
camera into selfie mode and you can add
some special overlay effects as well
so there's different filters i quickly
scan through those
when you're in selfie mode you can have
funny face alterations as well
so lots of different effects that you
can create here
so now let's look at the super zoom
video
the super zoom is a bit like paparazzi
video
also with different effects that you can
add to it
so for instance i want hearts on this
video
click on it and then it will zoom in and
you will see hearts popping down
and here is the stamp effect click on it
and there you go
when i do a focus video it makes the
background blurred
with rewind video you can make the video
playback by itself
and then finally there's the hands-free
video
if you click on hands-free you don't
have to keep on pressing the record
button
so you have more freedom in camera
movement when you choose this option
so these are the different types of
video that you can make on instagram
how to use instagram video options and
filters
to show you how the effects work on
instagram
i can go to instagram and then into the
story creation mode
and here i can just make a normal video
i can pan and move the video around a
bit
so the video is ready now and here i am
in the screen where i have the different
options to add creative effects to my
video
so this is what i can do
first i can download the video on my
phone by clicking the downward arrow
i can then get different effects i can
add stickers
i can play without sound i can draw on
the screen and i can add
text there are many different options
and when you click on the effect button
at the bottom you see the effects that
you can add to your video
there are effects that can be added when
there is a face
on the screen but there are also effects
that can be added as an
overlay over the video
we can also add stickers like a location
sticker and a mention
or a hashtag sticker interesting thing
about these text
type stickers is that when you add these
instagram will actually understand the
text
and will add them to the index for
search
you can easily move the stickers over
the screen
you can add a time or a date and you can
also add quizzes
so you can ask a question for instance
do you like this
and then people can actually answer by
dragging the slider
you can do a poll and there's a whole
range of other stickers
that you can add to your video
you can draw as well you can have a thin
line or a thick line
you can change the color you can do
special effects and you can erase as
well
so you can do many different effects
with this you could create an effect
where you wipe out the whole screen and
then with the eraser you can reveal
sections of the video
you can get text and then when you're
done with it you can add a video to your
stories
or save them as highlights on your
profile page or
you can share it on your newsfeed
monetizing your instagram videos
there are many different ways to make
money with instagram
you can make money as an influencer by
creating sponsored video
posts these are videos where you promote
a product from a brand
and the brand will reward you for giving
them access
to your followers tab influence is an
excellent app to connect brands with
influencers you can also sell your
videos
instagram is a great place to showcase
your content
2020 is an excellent website where you
can promote
and sell your video content and of
course there is
affiliate marketing where you can
promote your products
from your affiliate partners and get a
commission on each
sale sharesale is a website where you
can
search for potential affiliate partners
or why not sell your
instagram account if you no longer want
to manage it
famesweb is the place where you can do
this
finally instagram can also help you
indirectly to make money
you could use it to promote your youtube
channel and as we have learned in this
course
there are many ways of making money
through youtube
takumi is one of the leading online
platforms where small
influencers can get connected with big
global brands
when you have more than 1 000 followers
and you have good content
you will be able to use this network to
identify brands to work with
here are the takeaways of this lesson
video
has become the top content type shared
on instagram
and today instagram has a whole range of
options to create
and optimize your videos for the news
feed and for the stories
short videos of maximum 60 seconds are
best for instagram
instagram uses looping videos they start
automatically from the beginning after
the clip finishes
use looping videos to showcase a fun or
versatile product feature instagram has
many different video styles in the
stories camera
and once you've shot your story video
you have plenty of options to customize
them
takumi is an online platform where micro
influencers can connect with
big global brands to sell their original
content
greetings everyone this is rob sanders
and welcome to
this simply learn webinar today we're
going to talk about how
to increase instagram followers today's
webinar we're going to have some tips
and
best practices for you to take advantage
of to increase
instagram followers so let's get started
and talk a little bit about instagram so
instagram
is not really an up-and-coming platform
it
is already up and coming a lot of users
in fact 500 million daily active
instagram users
500 million daily the user base growth
of more than 300
year-over-year so it's growing and
growing and growing it's become more and
more popular
ever since it's launched back in 2010
and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can
upload photos tag those photos even
use and implement videos and photos have
become
very popular with the advent of mobile
technology that
the instagram app makes it easy for you
to post your photo
so there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's a
hundred million photos
plus uploaded daily and then there are
400 million stories posted daily so when
you post something
you can create a story out of it and
there's 400 million of those
per day and then there's more than 50
billion photos shared to date
so since 2010 platform net which is now
owned by facebook
has become really really popular a good
place for you
if you have your own company if you have
your own brand if you have your own
product
it's a good place for you to really
showcase that service that product that
brand
because of the user base how easy it is
to use
and the wide reach it has for you in
which to tell your story
so i mentioned there are lots of photos
shared today close to seven billion
dollars revenue
generated through instagram mobile so on
top of everything i just said
there's a lot of e-commerce going on
here too so instagram is a platform in
which
there's e-commerce integrated within the
platform
so as a business who offers a products
you can
actually generate revenue for yourself
on the flip side
instagram which is owned by facebook has
an opportunity to
sell advertising space on instagram so
instagram
is an e-commerce platform to say the
least in fact
instagram is because it's so popular
because it's part of facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on instagram
so amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags
you'll see some ads and then because
you'll see ads
because you'll see users you're going to
see businesses it's just
good place to really set up shop and
really tell your story
through the world of photos and videos
so 25 million plus
businesses have already migrated over to
instagram and that's growing and growing
and growing
so it's an opportunity for you to work
with other businesses
so the arrow is definitely pointing up
on instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos
so we're gonna go through some tips and
tricks today and we're gonna talk about
everything there is to know about
instagram and how to increase your
followers
so let's take a look at tip one here so
because
instagram is an application everything
you do on it
is through the application now you could
certainly
view a web page version on it but you
really can't do much
out of that so if i go to my instagram
account
for example using my desktop i could see
my profile
and i can edit my profile to a degree
but everything you're doing is through
the application
so when it comes to that tip one here is
take advantage of your bio
so regardless of what industry you are
you're in who you are you really want to
have a clear concise and compelling bio
why because this is your introduction to
the world
you want people to know who you are and
because
if you don't really become very clear to
people they're not going to follow you
so this is where it all starts you need
to take advantage of your bio
have a clear and concise bio and have a
link to your website or some contact
information
so to me this is where it all starts you
gotta have a bio because
that's what people are gonna look at and
they're gonna decide whether to follow
you or not
based on primarily that bio that's where
it all starts
so make sure you have a good bio that's
tip number one
so you'll have to make sure that your
landing page is also mobile optimized
since most
instagram users are on mobile so if
you're going to put a link to your
website
and somebody's on the instagram app and
they see your bio and they like it and
you have a link to your website
make sure that landing page they go to
is
mobile optimized so tip number two
everything you do
on instagram when it comes to posting
evolves around hashtags
so that's the backbone of the platform
just like most platforms out there
social media platforms like twitter
or facebook pinterest you're gonna have
hashtags accompany those posts so
instagram is no different but in this
case you really really want to take
advantage of the hashtag so
hashtags are there to help users find
your content
so you want to start out by using
hashtags that are relevant
to your business so if you're in the
food industry you're going to post
something related to
food do the appropriate amount of
research to find hashtags
that describe your brand and also are
being searched on instagram so what does
that mean that means do a little bit of
homework on instagram
you know see what searches or see what
other brands in your industry
are using for hashtags don't be afraid
to use the same hashtag
but mix it up hashtags are important so
don't be afraid to put a hashtag in
there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags
that are popular or people are using to
find information
so mix it up but the key here is
relevancy you want to make sure you
align your hashtags
with your content and making sure the
connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement
but it may not help with future goals
like long-term engagement
new interested followers and sales so
here really what i'm trying to say is
look
pick and choose your hashtags carefully
because if you use something broad or
something non-relevant
yeah you may get that click to your
instagram page
but that doesn't necessarily mean
somebody's going to follow you or that
doesn't mean
really mean somebody's going to be
interested in what you have to offer
so if you use something really popular
and broad yes
you're going to get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time
so according to sprout social which is a
social media scheduling platform among
other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform
and posting content via their platform
they have data and they're telling us
based on the data they've collected that
the best time to post is between
2 and 3 p.m and the best day to post is
thursday now
that may be all fine and true according
to a sprout social
study and so you may want to go with
this
2 to 3 p.m and this is probably local in
case you're wondering what time zone
we're
referring to so this is all local to you
so go ahead and try that out try 2 to 3
p.m on thursday the thing is what you're
gonna have to do
eventually is figure out what the best
time to post is okay so if you're
pointing out a lot of content and you're
putting out content
throughout the week at certain times of
the day or throughout the day
you're gonna have to determine which
time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post
at what point of the day what day of the
week and so you're gonna
really have to lean on a social media
platform
to help you determine that because
they're gonna have the data
that you need to determine what the best
time of day to post is okay so we'll
talk about social media platforms here
shortly we just know that when you post
post with some rationale in mind ask
yourself before you even push that
publish button or
before you even schedule that post this
time a day
in this day of the week makes sense so
you always want to post at the right
time because you could be missing your
audience
so remember when you do this you're
going to be working with
some platform and instagram also has
some analytics for business accounts so
instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well
so let's move over to tip four here
steal
followers from your competitors okay
so if you're dealing in a very
competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very
very easy to see who's following them so
the easiest way to do this is just
interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user
like or comment on their photos and so
the more you engage with people the more
you stand to gain from them
so you could see who your competitors
followers are
and you can add them as a follower just
by following them
so start engaging with them if they're
liking your competitors brand
then what the chance of them liking your
brand could be great
so check out who your competitors
followers are
if they seem like somebody who you would
want to be following your brand
then go ahead and interact with them and
how you interact is again you can like
something that they post or you can
comment on something that they posted
engage with them okay it doesn't take
that much time it's a good way
to gain followers so if we're on
instagram
we can simply just click on the brand's
followers so here i can see this brand
has 127 followers and here i can see all
the followers
and what i could do is simply just click
on one of the followers and i can go
to their profile and from there i could
see what they've posted
in terms of videos and images and i can
like or comment so just doing something
as simple as this
gets you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you
so tip five pay for sponsored posts and
product reviews
so a number of ways you could do this
here so pay for a sponsored post
so you can find an employer who said it
satisfies a couple of requirements
they have large following and an email
address in the profile
so you can connect with them and ask
them for sponsored post pricing
so it's as simple as that as reaching
out to somebody who has a large
following okay
so if you do this then it's going to put
you in front of a large number of people
and so by doing this it'll help expose
your brand to that larger audience and
help build your
credibility because you're connecting
with somebody who has a large audience
as well
so do a little bit of homework find
people out there in your industry who
has a large following
and make sure they have that email
address in their profile so you can
contact them and when you contact them
you know ask them for sponsored post
pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shout out so that's
the key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do
then it's all about asking them and
connecting with them
on being a sponsor to one of your posts
okay you want to get yourself
out there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that
okay so tip six we want to use geotags
for easier discoverability okay so
tag your images videos or stories by
tagging the location
city or venue where it was posted from
so very easy to do as you're posting
just go ahead and and there's an option
in there to say hey where are you
located
or what city are you located in so
locations
have their own feed and stories which
you can contribute to
so go ahead and add that extra element
to your tags
so if somebody's in that location the
chance of them engaging
are going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because
if you're local and you're posting your
location
then again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you so tip seven
use instagram stories to attract
followers and grow your user base a
story is a really big feature
on instagram so what stories could be
used for
is just show footage of an environment
so it could be your office it could be
your home it could be you know the
playground it could be the golf course
it could be anywhere that you want to
show vintage of so you want to post
new relevant to your industry so if
you're in the food industry hey
why not go in the back into the kitchen
and post a story about
how a particular bread or cake is made
okay show off your product so if you are
in that food industry and say you're in
the pizza making
business perfect opportunity to show
people
via an instagram story how to make that
pizza and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use
how unique is your particular product
and that's really what you want to get
across when you do a story
you want to show something unique and
relevant that's going to grasp people's
attention you can promote a company
event so
if you're celebrating say 200 000
subscribers
create a youtube video or you can create
an instagram story
it works just as well so you can endorse
your company's blog post you can post
positive user reviews so these are all
features of a story
increase interactivity with polls
sliders etc
and then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
instagram stories is a really big
feature with instagram
check it out you know you can just do a
search for instagram stories
in fact let's get some of you users
involved what best practices do you have
when creating instagram stories
why don't you go ahead and share your
instagram story with us
by putting that instagram story in the
comment section below
so we want to get everybody involved
here because there's thousands upon
thousands of great instagram stories out
there
to be shown and viewed and engaged with
so go ahead and share your instagram
story if you have any other tips or
tricks
then go ahead and put those in the
comments section so that everybody can
benefit from them
so the only thing to keep in mind when
you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote
something to your user base so always
keep that in the back your mind
you know for me i always go back to what
industry are you in if you're in the
food industry
hey you know people who are following
you are interested in food if you're a
pizza
company you know show off that pizza if
you're a bakery
show off how you make your breads and
goods baked goods
whatever it is you have show it off
because if somebody's following you
that's what they're interested
in so tip number eight highlight
important stories
so you want to highlight highlights
serve as the easiest way to create a
first impression for a potential
follower so with highlights can be used
to tease what your contents about
create a trailer for what your brand
offers promote
and promote your product highlights are
there it's a good feature
it's a first impression for potential
followers so it teases what the contents
about
it creates a trailer so to speak for
your brand and promote your product
so use highlights and again any users
out there who have good examples of
highlights go ahead and put those in the
content section
or comment section uh right below this
video so remember stories have only a 24
hour
life span so highlights can be used to
give them a second wind okay so
highlights serve a purpose it teases
what the contents about
it promotes the product and it really
kind of accentuates that story
tip number nine ask for followers so
sometimes people need a little push
before they can follow you on instagram
even if they enjoy your content so
you can ask users to become your
followers in the caption
the comment section even work it into
your content so in other words
when you're posting something don't be
afraid to say hey follow me
you know i got some good stuff here be
confident you don't want to do it for
every post of course
but you know pick and choose if you feel
you have a really good post
you know really good image that you
think is going to gain a lot of
followers and engagers
then you don't necessarily need to put a
caption in there but if
if it is popular then go ahead and say
hey this is a popular post
you know think about following me or put
something in the comment section you
want to do it kind of succinctly
you don't want to be begging but just
work it in to some degree okay but don't
be afraid have some confidence
and asking for followers so when you do
this it's very similar to how we do it
on youtube
so you can ask viewers to subscribe to
their channels at the end of the video
so it's if on youtube
basically you're saying hey if you like
what we have go ahead and subscribe
it's no different on instagram if you
have something you've posted
just go and say hey you like this you
know go ahead and follow us it's that
simple
so tip number 10 take on the latest
trends to get more followers so
align your content to cater to trendy
topics or hashtags to improve engagement
and discoverability
so really what we're trying to say
here's your competitors follow
influencers what are the latest trends
and you can get an
idea of the latest trends by looking at
hashtags so what hashtags
are trending which ones are people using
the most
so really what you want to do is
whatever's trending in your industry
you know ride that wave so to speak now
it doesn't have to take on your entire
profile but there's nothing wrong with
one or two posts
if something's really taking on
popularity then go ahead and post about
it as well
you know for example in the wine
industry if there's a new wine that
really came out that's really
gaining some popularity go ahead and
post about it with the same hashtag and
with the unique hashtag
so don't be afraid to you know ride the
wave of popularity so to speak because
it shows that you know you know what
you're talking about it adds some
credibility and it's going to get some
you know viewers over to your instagram
profile
so keep in mind you need to keep your
content relevant because
if your audience is interested in what
you have to offer
then they're going to be engaged however
you know if you're joining the
discussion in a relevant manner
keeping in mind whether your audience
will interact or not is important
but just always keep in mind you always
want to stay within your industry and
relevancy for your target audience
so tip number 11 run contests and
giveaways and so
just like on youtube just like on
facebook i mean
instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure
by running contests since most followers
would tag their friends to let them know
about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
what's an idea of a contest well
again if you're running a pizza parlor
you know you could say hey
what's your favorite pizza or give me
your favorite pizza ideas
and you can run a contest and you know
you can have people even
create their own pizza and post an image
of it you can have people
create stories on the best ways in which
they create pizza
or their experience in another pizza
parlor there's lots of things you can do
to create a contest and you don't always
have to give
something away you can just do something
for fun especially if you have a lot of
followers if you have a lot of followers
then somebody's going to take part in it
so
don't be afraid to run contests just to
make it fun and light it up a little bit
so each tag can bring you a new audience
member who could be a potential follower
so anytime you run a contest people are
gonna
tag their friends to let them know about
that contest so those friends
are going to come over and likely engage
so that's the beauty of running a
contest or giveaway
is chances are word's going to spread
and it's going to get you some new
followers so that's the
the end benefits so to speak but the
real benefit
is keeping your audience engaged so tip
number 12
we want to stay consistent with post so
having a consistent
pace and theme for your post can have a
huge impact to convert visitors so when
we say
consistent you know if you're again that
pizza parlor
stay within pizza you could branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to
you know as a complementary factor to
the pizza okay but don't talk about
hamburgers
if you're focused in on pizza so we want
to stay consistent
with your theme this method involves
less effort with a faster production of
instagram content so that mean what
we're really trying to say here
is focus stay focused on who you are
if you do that if you're consistent and
you're gaining some followers and that's
what people are coming to you for the
content that you're good at for the
industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out
then it's gonna muddy the water suppose
so to speak and
you're probably gonna get less
engagement so set a theme on instagram
by maintaining consistency
and your personality filters colors and
layout and really what i'm
referring to is post and when you have
post something you're you're really
creating a personality for yourself okay
so if you're in fashion for example
and you're in the genes industry well
jeans jeans jeans right
that's your personality accentuate it
with different outfits related to jeans
but
you know when you start talking about
dresses and shoes and that
kind of blurs your your personality a
bit
so if you stay consistent with thin
jeans and outfits that go with jeans
then
i think people are going to start to
pick up on that personality so tip 13
keep track of your instagram following
so you can
analyze the growth of your channel with
tools like socialblade
that could tell you how many followers
you've lost over time and how engaged
they are okay so you can use
data gather from here and from instagram
business account to diagnose where
you're faltering so
let's take a look at socialblade as an
example here so
if i go over here i'm gonna go to
socialblade here i can enter in
basically any account after i register
and i could see
how that account has performed you know
where they rank
you know how many uploads they have what
country they focused on
what industry and the beauty here is i
could see
and i'm looking at youtube as an example
i could see
you know how my post to perform well you
could do this
for instagram you could do it for
facebook so you can really get an
idea of how your account's performing
so socialblade's a great platform for
measuring it and again you do also have
instagram business insights so with
instagram business insights
basically what you're going to do is
you're going to go to your app
right and then from the app you could
basically
look at your insights from there so in
the app itself you're going to click on
the upper right
three lines and from there you're going
to see insights and when you go to
insights
you're also gonna see you know what your
reach is how many impressions
and some engagement metrics terms of
your audience where they're located
the age range okay you're gonna also see
some content related information
so there's a lot you could see from the
instagram insights
analytics insights but you can also see
additional information from socialblade
so the key here is when you're looking
at
your data you want to look for patterns
in post
what posts receive the most amount of
engagement so if you see something
working obviously replicate it you know
you don't want to replicate it
immediately but
make note of it and use it for future
content so tip 14
use instagram ads so instagram ads give
you
complete control over advertisements so
how they appear and who sees them so
with instagram ads you can run photos
you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so
we mention this on other webinars for
facebook advertising
it's worth repeating so if i go back
into say facebook ads manager i can
pick and choose my placements and really
what i want to do
is pick and choose for example instagram
and so i have
instagram feed i have instagram stories
so
and i could see what the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on instagram so with
instagram you can run stories you can
run videos
single image ads you can run carousel to
really
you could put your best forward meaning
take the post that's performing well
and maybe you want to advertise that
promote it so
you're going to run this through
facebook ads manager and it's going to
tell you
you know what your audience size is your
potential reach okay what your daily
results would be
so you're going to get all that
information when you run your ads on
facebook ads manager but it's a great
opportunity for you to really
push forward if you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push for
that promotion other advantages scalable
pricing
self-serve and instant robust reporting
and highly refined audience retargeting
so all of that is in the facebook ads
manager you can get
all the reporting units you need meaning
you know who
saw the ad do they click on it okay you
can refine that target audience you can
go back
into facebook ads manager and refine who
your audience is
so lots of flexibility here and
advertising on instagram but the key
here is if you want to run
advertising on instagram you know think
about what it is you're trying to
promote if you feel
something needs to get promoted then go
ahead and you know you can either
again reach out to somebody and have
them sponsor it or you can run it as an
advertisement so
let's move on to tip 15. so we want to
create
visually attractive and eye-catching ads
so if you are gonna run ads you know
here's some things to keep in mind
okay you want to use images that are
natural and seem native okay you don't
want to use any stock photography
first off you want to use something that
you've done okay you want to minimize
the amount of text
so let the image do the talking you want
to ensure your caption relates to the
image and resonates with your audience
okay so you have an opportunity to add
some text below the image
okay so make sure it resonates and then
of course use hashtags to show
your ads to target your audience but a
wider relevant audience so hashtags do
play a role here as well
so these are some tips if you're going
to create
ads you want to take these into account
the whole point of the ad
is to get people over to either web page
or to your profile page
okay so that they can engage and take
action so instagram ads
will help showcase your product service
or brand in a way that's memorable
and unique so if you really want to get
your
vision your brand your product out there
in front of a lot of people
then advertising on instagram is a good
way to do that
so since we've been talking about pizza
throughout this webinar
there's a good instagram a profile here
about pizza
you know i'm getting hungry just looking
at this hopefully this is an example for
all veg and non-veg pizza consumers
i mean you can see this profile here
they got the website
you know they got the handle okay so
they have a lot of followers so
you know if i'm in the pizza industry i
can go ahead and you know click on their
followers and see who
who's following them who they're
following so
some really good shots of pizza here it
looks like
you know a lot of people are wearing
were involved in this
you could see lots of different examples
here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza
which you know most people enjoy you
know most
and you can kind of appreciate you know
how
much of an advantage instagram can be
because it really you can accentuate
photos you can have fun with it
you can really run some contests here
you know give us your best pizza photo
so here you know you could say use daily
pizza as a hashtag for feature okay so
they're even encouraging you
to use a specific hashtag so you can
really do a lot here
on instagram this is just a good example
of what you can do and have fun with
you know with an example like pizza just
to give you some ideas
so let's move on to tip 16. take
advantage of instagram tools
so you can use scheduling tools like
later
hootsuite and buffer so i can't stress
this enough
you know when it comes to measuring the
engagement of your instagram
post you're definitely going to need a
social media tool so
you're also going to need it if you do a
lot of
you know posting on instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com
so if i go later here i can see you know
i can use this to
upload my images to my profile
so here you can see it's scheduled
throughout the day of the week
so that way we're not overlapping you
know we're scheduling
based on the times of the day that
people are going to look at this
so you know here i could see you know
particular stories
if any stories are posted okay i can
look at it from a weekly or monthly
preview
i could see what's been posted okay and
more importantly as a schedule tool i
can also see the analytics
i could see you know how many were
posted how many followers
so this is really important because you
know if my profile is growing
i want to be able to see what posts
perform best
what the audience was like you know by
gender by
age by location so again i can look at
it by post performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details
about you know what's driving engagement
so here you can see some hashtags that
this become
a particular company is using on
instagram so here you can see
how many posts with this hashtag you
know and what
and kind of engagement did they receive
do they receive likes
comments impressions how much reach do
they get
how many saves and it really just does
go into detail
so later does a good job i like this
platform
especially for instagram it's great for
scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the instagram
analytics
you can really lean on you know this
particular platform to get a really good
idea
as to you know how particular posts are
performing remember if a post is
performing
you want to reuse it at a certain point
in time okay learn
from best practices learn from what's
working learn from what's not working if
something's not working then don't do it
again
so you can really get a good breakdown
here and later.com so
remember these tools place an emphasis
on automation okay
enabling you to automatically post at a
scheduled time so
you want to lock it in at a certain
period of time and i have to worry about
it so it allows you to really hone
in on that particular time of the day
and day of the week so that you're
really maximizing
your chances of getting good engagement
okay so develop your own signature
styles
to set up a style and content theme so
that you're able to stand out
amongst the various competitors so you
know again just going back to our pizza
example
lots of good photos of pizza and but
this is their style this is who they are
you know they're not a particular brand
they're just you know people who like
pizza okay and they're having fun with
it
okay so that's their style you know
they're posting really good
shots of all these different types of
pizza different styles different
toppings
and just to give you an idea of how
popular pizza is and what you can do
with it okay so
again this is a good basic example
um of what you can do with
something as simple as pizza so don't be
afraid to experiment
you know try something different with
your profile you know do something
different you don't always have to
follow what everybody else is doing
that's the great thing about instagram
it allows you to be
free and creative in fact if anybody has
any styles that have worked for them
you know feel free to put something in
the comment section we'd love to hear
your thoughts
so tip 18 use user engagement to your
advantage
so i just mentioned that using the later
example
so we want to be able to learn
from what's working and not working so
user generated
content shows off your brand to be
authentic and improves your relationship
with your followers so
you know you want to be unique with the
content you're posting
so if you do that you're likely to build
that relationship
and you know increase your followers and
you want to be able to see
of that user generated content that ugc
which is performing which is not
performing okay so
basically your followers and your
audience are telling you what's working
and not working so take advantage of
that
remember going back to hashtags you
could set up your own unique hashtag
and ask your users to post images or
videos relating to that which you can
post in your brand's account so just
like the whole pizza thing they're
saying hey look
you know use daily pizza for a feature
okay
that's a good example of something you
can do as well so you could set up a
unique hashtag
and say hey use this hashtag and that'll
help you gain
some followers that'll help you gain
some notoriety and some visibility on
your platform
tip 19 use high quality images and
videos
just like on youtube just like on
facebook instagram is no different
images must be of high quality authentic
and original i mean again one more time
going back to the pizza
these images look to be pretty high
quality i mean if you have a decent
mobile phone that's all it takes
a mobile phone with a camera that is
that's all it usually takes
you know you want to be able to get that
that right shot
you don't want to use anything that's of
low quality because it really is gonna
take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video
or whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos
needs to be fun and informational
without causing the user to lose
interest so
you know if you're going to create a
video you know go ahead and you know
make you can make it short
make it fun okay you can see here these
guys are just showing you how pizza's
made doesn't take
a long time they're just going through
the motions they're not boring you with
details they're not talking
really quick and easy just to give you
an idea it doesn't have to be as serious
it can be fun
so video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest
that's the key short sweet unique
authentic
and fun have fun with it so worth
repeating
don't use stock images on instagram
because
you know they don't really bode well for
your particular brand
you know it's instagram it allows you to
post
original content that's the whole
purpose of it okay and on the video side
be concise high quality and
informational enough
okay so you have to hold the user's
attention here so
when we say concise you know don't make
it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer
and if you can do that you're likely
gonna hold the user's attention so tip
20 promote
your instagram page and other social
media channels
so facebook and instagram are part of
the same family
so this seems like a natural but you
know don't be afraid to
promote it on other channels like
pinterest or
or youtube the whole idea is to get
users to your instagram page
and encourage them to follow it so you
know you can always
put that url in you know other platforms
like youtube
nothing wrong with that at all okay you
can also promote your page
offline with print ads and during other
relevant events
and then i would even take this to
further is you'll probably see
you know an instagram logo on a web page
along with other social media icons so
you always want to help promote
instagram on your web page as well but
you can do it for offline
with print ads so you can simply just
put
you know whatever your your slug is for
instagram whatever your id
is whatever you're using on instagram
that's what you can use don't be afraid
to promote it
offline or online instagram is a social
media platform that needs no
introduction
with nearly 1 billion monthly active
users
and 500 million daily active users
instagram is a platform drive with
marketing potential
more than 7 billion revenue has been
generated from instagram mobile
and it's home to more than 2 million
advertisers
not only that marketing on instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one third of the
people
using the app have used it to purchase
products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to instagram's
parent company facebook
instagram has access to just about all
advertising features offered by facebook
ads
with this you can advertise to people
based on their age
location gender interests and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships
you can stimulate conversion with your
followers and build a connection with
them
you'll also get a greater understanding
of what your followers like and dislike
based on their engagement
this enables you to make content they
enjoy more and increase the chance of
converting a user to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page
that's where they make the first
impression of your brand and that's why
it's important for your bio to be
informative captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product
the type of content you'll be posting
brand hashtags
links to other social media platforms
and more
your bio should also include a url to
where you want to drive traffic to
be it your brand's website or a page for
a particular product
make sure to track this link as well to
see how much traffic it brings
here's an example of how samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well
it's to the point and covers everything
you need to know about it
next up at number 2 we have create a
content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
content calendar
a content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts
it'll help you plan ahead and automate
the process of publishing your posts
when your audience is most active
a calendar helps you decide what content
caption
hashtags videos goes live on what day
date or time a consistent post schedule
will enable you to make the most out of
instagram
it'll also keep your audience engaged
and also give you access to historical
posts if you want to repost your older
content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you'll need
to pay for it too
the ad options are pretty similar to
what you have on facebook
like audience segmentation based on
likes interactions buying habits and
more
you also have a variety of ad formats to
choose from like story ads image ads
video ads collection ads and more
moreover they can also be set up from
facebook ads manager
here's an example from an ad from body
shop in which they're using a single
image ad
the advertising works because of its
interesting creative
and attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link
let's go to number four have a visually
consistent feed
instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content
to authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry
what works nowadays are candid shots
muted earthly tones with a low key
editing style
your content must feel down-to-earth and
your brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have acidically pleasing images
and a somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for
your content following an understandable
and interesting aesthetic depending on
the product you're trying to sell
now for number five tell a story the
images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them
this makes it more likely that they feel
closer to your brand and by your
products
your captions can tell stories that can
help your brand appear more human and
build deeper connections with your
audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face
here's an example of how the page
patagonia talks about forests in america
each of their posts tells stories about
a different issue that affects nature
their brand on instagram revolves around
bringing awareness to such issues
that's the kind of stories you should
tell with your brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your posts showing up
on the explore tab for everyone to see
and getting lost in the sea of content
your hashtags shouldn't be too generic
like new year or hash style
since they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and
industry specific keywords to connect
with your followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy
untargeted and unprofessional find out
what and how many hashtags your
competitors use and how you can do
something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and
involve your brand name in some way
let's now go to number seven
take advantage of ugc ugc or user
generated content gives your followers
to further involve themselves with your
brand
ugc also by them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to
ugc can be used to convert followers
into advocates of your brand
here's an example of how starbucks uses
user-generated content
and takes advantages of their audience
to advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed in products stored at
starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and
improve brand loyalty next up number
eight
take advantage of video ads most
instagramers state that users have
visited websites
searched or told a friend after being
influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising
video advertisements aren't too far
behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to instagram ads
single video ads that can create 60
second ads corrosives are a combination
of images and videos
and instagram stories that enable you to
combine images and videos to create
visually attractive ads
here's an example of the brand pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well short videos and captions
now for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry
and enable you to show off your brand to
a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and
they have a closer connection with their
audience
here we can see how ralph lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products
the influencer showing off the latest
ralph lauren has to offer
this encourages his interested followers
to check out the page and buy something
for themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways
contests enable your audience to engage
with your brand with 3.5 times more
likes and 64 times the comments
you can give away a product or a service
which enables you to boost engagement
and brand awareness contests and
giveaways need to be planned
brands need to be partnered with contest
rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important
you would need to track your contest
performance and promote the results on
other social media platforms as well
here's an example of a contest run by
domino's pizza which encourages people
to contribute their own short stories
and connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates
even giving your story the chance to
show up in the explore section
it can also help make your brand seem
more approachable and authentic
adding links to the instagram stories
can also help with driving traffic to
your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline
still has a few advantages to offer to
the savvy marketer
igtv provides you a unique mobile
friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well
like featurettes and interviews another
new tool they have introduced is
instagram reels
instagram's answer to tick tock
instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips
and since it released very recently it's
rife with marketing potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn
identify effective hashtags visual
styles and the best times to post
doing this you can develop the best
practices for your brand
social listening and analytics will help
you fine-tune your marketing strategy
and increase instagram engagement
now let's get started first off let's
have a look at an introduction
to facebook facebook was first launched
in february 2004
and was initially known as the facebook
in 2005 it removed d from its name
and it has now become the facebook we
all know today
it is now the world's most popular
social media
and social networking service next
let's have a look at instagram it was
launched in 2010
for ios and then in 2012 for android
by kevin systrom and mike krieger
instagram has now evolved to become one
of the fastest growing social media
platforms in the world
in april 2012 thanks to its popularity
it was acquired by facebook for
approximately one billion dollars in
cash in stock
now let's compare some stats between
facebook and instagram
first let's have a look at the worldwide
stats
first off facebook like i mentioned
earlier
facebook is the largest social media
platform in the world
reaching almost 60.6 of the internet
it has 2.5 billion monthly active users
and approximately 1.6 billion active
users
in fact as of jan 2020 the us has
approximately 190 million
and india has approximately 280 million
facebook users
an indication of a market that's still
ripe for the picking
now let's have a look at instagram
instagram although having released
significantly later
earns its title of the fastest growing
social media platform
with 1 billion monthly active users and
500 million daily users
in the united states there are
approximately 120 million
and india has close to 88 million
instagram users
next up let's have a look at the next
statistic age group of the user base
first off facebook although there's a
general opinion among the younger
population that facebook isn't hip
or isn't used all that much anymore
this statistic has something different
to say turns out more than 65 percent of
facebook users
are between the ages of 25 and 34.
for instagram it's no surprise that 71
of the user base
are under the age of 35. next
let's compare the usage time of both
these platforms
let's take facebook first in the united
states
users spend approximately 1 hour on
facebook every day
in india users spend an average of 3
hours a day on facebook
shockingly high numbers for a platform
that's assumed to be dead
isn't it on the other hand in the united
states
users spend 23 minutes on average on
instagram
in india users spend approximately 45
minutes
now for the most important stat
marketing
for facebook 86 of marketers
use it for advertising instagram is used
by 71 percent of businesses
for their marketing requirements now
let's have a look at some industries
that can work
well on both these platforms if you do
belong to any of these industries
if you're not taking advantage of these
platforms you're missing out
so let's have a look at some industries
that can capitalize on facebook
food and beverage companies news and
media
e-commerce automobile
and package goods next time you're on
facebook
take a closer look at your feed there's
a good chance you'll see most of these
industries
post on it next up instagram
we have industries like fashion
athleisure
cosmetics automobiles and food and
beverages
i can guarantee that if you take a
closer look you can find
all these industries advertising on
instagram
now let's take a closer look at how
facebook can help with marketing
first off let's have a look at facebook
business pages
now these are basically platforms where
you can create an online presence
for your organization for free
moreover they've got some great
advantages to offer you as well
first off your business page can keep
your customers or potential customers
informed it can be about a new product
launch
a webinar a live broadcast a new store
opening
anything whatever it is it can go on
your facebook business page
it connects people with your products
and services with your page
you get greater visibility letting
people know about the products
and services that you offer you can
offer customer service as well
in fact according to american express 90
of users use customer service as a
deciding factor
for whether or not they continue to do
business with an organization
so customer service is pretty important
like i mentioned earlier
your business page provides a place
where you can offer your followers
offers and other advantages and finally
the page lets you build a community a
highly targeted community that has a
higher possibility
of buying your products and services
next
we have facebook groups with facebook
groups you can build a community of like
individuals some of the advantages that
come with this are
it provides a highly targeted audience i
mentioned earlier that business pages
provide you with a highly targeted
audience
groups take that to the next level it
enables everyone to learn from one
another
with a large community there's a good
chance that some members
know things that others don't your group
will enable them to communicate with
each other
and learn these new things you also get
honest feedback
your customers who are also likely part
of the group will be able to give
their feedback on how they like your
product and perhaps even give you tips
on how to improve
now since your group is filled with a
community that's highly interested in
your brand
you can also increase engagement in an
organic manner
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get more leads and
conversions
next facebook has events with facebook
events your organization
will be able to mobilize your brand and
enable online consumer marketing
basically meaning that you have a
platform for letting people know
about important announcements not to
mention there's also the opportunity to
get some free advertising done
events also help you increase brand
awareness
most people get to know about your brand
by attending the event
or just seeing the promotion for it now
let's have a look
at facebook stories for groups and pages
a feature that is available for both
groups and pages
it provides you the ability to
appropriately represent your brand or
business
directly from your mobile device or
desktop
now some of its advantages are that it
helps you engage with your audience
with stuff other than the usuals like
articles
videos and other similar posts this way
you can also
vary the kind of content that you post
moreover stories can help you humanize
your brand
rather than seeming like you're
pandering to your audience or seeing
them only as potential leads or
customers
stories help your brand show that you're
genuinely interested in your audience
you can also reach your appropriate
audience with greater frequency
next facebook has facebook messenger
with messenger you can connect and
interact with your audience at a
personal level
in the last few years messenger has
proved itself to be a great marketing
tool
it helps acquire more customers now
people
are more loyal to a brand that generally
cares about them
and by directly interacting with them
through messenger
their loyalty towards you is certainly
said to improve
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get
a greater number of transaction and even
if a customer doesn't give you a
transaction
at least you're increasing your brand
awareness
then we have facebook live facebook live
gives you a platform
to interact with your audience in real
time it can be used to diversify your
content
providing your audience with something
different from what they've received
from your brand initially
live can also be used to show what
happens behind the scenes in your
organization
further helping humanize your brand and
finally you can also provide
instant questions and answers to your
audience increasing
engagement with them next we have the
facebook shop
the facebook shop is a business page tab
application
that enables your customers to purchase
your products
directly from your store it also has the
following advantages
firstly you can use the shop to drive
new sales
you can give the customers who are on
the fence about your product
a small push by engaging them and how
can you do that
with deals and promotions you can also
reward advocates of your brand with
special benefits to be availed from your
store
and finally you can build brand
awareness and recognition
now let's have a look at facebook ads
facebook ads help spread product or
brand awareness in the news feed of a
specific
targeted audience on facebook now some
of the advantages of facebook ads
are that they help increase brand
awareness
they enable you to advertise your
products and services to the appropriate
audience
and it provides you with greater reach
while making you spend lesser amounts of
money
it also helps you re-advertise or
re-target
your products to an existing audience
and finally
it helps increase revenue sales and
leads
if you guys are interested in learning
about facebook ads you can check out our
facebook ads video
i'll add it in the live chat so you can
check it out if you're interested
now let's have a look at the final
feature facebook offers to help you with
marketing
facebook insights i'm sure all of you
have heard about google analytics
let's just say this is facebook's
version of that
with insights you get information that
can help you refine your
brand strategy by tracking and measuring
results
it can help you determine reach and
engagement actions
people who are viewing your posts when
your fans are online
the type of posts that are working for
you and much much more
that brings us to the end of the ways
facebook helps you with marketing
now let's move on to instagram first off
we have instagram business accounts
instagram business accounts enable
brands
to be recognized as businesses now it
also has the following benefits to offer
it's only with a business account that
you can get instagram insights
we'll talk about insights in a little
more detail in a little bit
you can also add a contact button on
your profile
enabling users to connect with you
directly
you can also specify what kind of
service you offer
by adding what industry you belong to in
your bio
and finally you also have the ability to
add links to your instagram stories
now i'm sure you've all seen the see
more option in your stories
so now you know how that shows up now if
you guys are interested in finding out
how you can increase followers on
instagram
you can check out our video on the same
topic of the same name
i'll add the link in the live chat next
let's talk about instagram stories
with instagram stories you have the
ability to grow engagement
build brand awareness and to drive sales
you can also use stories to provide
recent updates about your brand now some
of the advantages of instagram stories
are that they help businesses grow their
audience and can
enable them to engage with their
audience regularly
with stories you can also drive traffic
to other websites
like your company's website it can also
help diversify your content
setting it apart from the usual videos
and photos next up let's talk about
instagram dms or direct messages
dms help you grow your business by
interacting with customers at a personal
level
it can also help build connections with
your users by building a personal
connection with your followers
their loyalty towards your brand is
improved
not only that it helps you make or grow
your connections within the industry
and as an extension of the last few
points this leads
to easier lead generation and increased
sales
next up we have igtv now ittv is a
platform that's gotten
really famous recently it enables your
brand to get closer to its audience
and enables it to be discovered by new
people
other benefits include greater
visibility of your products and services
having the ability to educate and
entertain your audience
improved engagement and greater chances
of conversions
finally it also helps build a community
of a highly targeted audience
next we have instagram live instagram
live enables you to communicate with
your audience in real time
further improving your discoverability
and strengthening your connection with
the audience
moreover it provides a lot of visibility
your followers are immediately notified
when you go on live stream
and finally it helps you interact with
your audience in real time
this helps further humanize your brand
next we have instagram ads instagram ads
provides you with control over
advertisements
you decide how they appear and who sees
them like facebook
instagram has a number of different ad
types to offer
they are photo ads video ads carousel
ads
slideshow ads and stories ads
next up instagram offers an instagram
shop
the shop helps you incorporate your
product catalog with your instagram
profile
at some points even enabling users to
access the shop directly
from an image showing the same product
one of the major advantages of the
instagram shop
is that it provides easy product
discoverability
and since it provides visual marketing
it also leads to more sales
and finally instagram insights
instagram's answer to facebook insights
and google analytics
insights is an analytical tool that
provides data
on follower demographics their actions
and your brand content
it helps determine engagement
impressions and reach
best and worst performing content
profile visits
website clicks and much more and there
you go
that's every way facebook and instagram
can help you with marketing
now we've laid out the facts for you
keep in mind your requirements
and make a wise choice and with that we
have come to an end of this
instagram fill course for 2021 i hope it
was informative and interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team of experts will be happy
to solve all your queries
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here